foreign
[Music]
I will tell you I've never seen anything
like it holy
is the craziest I think I've ever seen
everything okay
oh languaged baby's here
yo what up everybody Roy and kitty here
I'm gonna pick a stock and talk about
why I think it's interesting and that
stock is Gamestop I love this guy
retail Traders have hooked into GameStop
I think they think it's a good
investment it looks like there's one guy
driving all the buying
the money man happy to take it
Wall Street is betting that this company
is gonna fail if it fails these hedge
fund people make a ton of money 70
000 people have watched this video
[Music]
if he's in I'm in if he's an honest
GameStop those shares not stopping don't
stop it's only gonna go up when they hit
I'm gonna buy you a mansion let's drink
to that my brother is a nerd Wall Street
must be seen this right you should
probably dial in holy [__] do you have a
minute I uh
um
babe how much did we make today five
million how much did we lose today a
billion and yesterday four million and
yesterday a billion
you got rich dudes pissing in their
pants right now they're coming after you
we need to talk about the Game Stop
situation
retail Traders always lose you've been
served Wall Street cheated
surprise surprise you have to testify
before Congress the game has changed
[Music]
what's the point of winning the race if
you let some idiot steal the prize a lot
of people feel the system is broken the
whole idea of the stock market is if
you're smart and maybe with a little
luck you can make your fortune certainly
not anymore
there's no hope for the little guy
[__] balls
maybe now there is yeah
[Music]
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
I tried to talk him out of it
yeah
don't use that word that way I mean
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
this is insane Squirtle mutant karate I
want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rat
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool
super fun and then everyone will think
we're cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
huh I can't believe there are other
mutants you want to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we're gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
peoples they got to go okay um sort of a
twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dog
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdom Rafael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
talk I dream about fighting every night
you've got a rage problem right it's not
a problem
do you know what the greatest thing
about America is you can make things
happen here like nowhere else
you have the power to create your own
future you can be anything you can do
anything
you want to sell high-end stuffed
Himalayan cats understuffed actually for
greater posability we're professionals
we're giving the people what they need
did you see the latest numbers we broke
the entire internet thing
should you go big or you go home
[Music]
Ty would tell you he did it all
which is as crazy as believing the
stuffed animals are gold
did you see the truck crash
insane poor beanies
this has always been my company company
we created together I have to be so
dramatic I mean my salary's been reduced
75 yeah I'm just doing what's necessary
you know running the real actual
business over here
[Music]
my life is this company can I see where
it's going oh there are signs of real
trouble genius is one percent
inspiration 99 presentation
it's not how the saying goes
everything good that's happened to me is
because of you guys we are bonded
forever
have you considered poisoning him
countless times
[Music]
I have our perfect Partners lined up
Jehovah's Witnesses the greatest
one-on-one salesman in the world how
brilliant is that
[Music]
I'm gonna go
you're dead to me
about me
[Music]
I only want to speak to Oprah Winfrey
has she reached out
oh
[Music]
hey Barbie
can I come to your house today sure
I don't have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and planned choreography in a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool okay
The Best Day Ever it is the best day
ever and so is yesterday and so is
tomorrow and every day for now until
forever
you guys ever think about dying
when my heart breaks some things have
been happening that might be related
cold shower falling off my roof and my
heels are on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
what do I have to do you have to go to
the real world
and go back to your regular life or you
can know the truth about the universe
the choice is now
the first one the high heel you have to
want to know okay do it again
Spotify
[Music]
[Applause]
coming with you okay
[Music]
wow this is the real world what's going
on why are these men looking at me yeah
they're also staring at me
[Music]
Barbie in the real world that's
impossible if this got out this could
mean extremely weird things for our
world
catastrophic
navigated Barbie since we were like five
years old oh
no one rests and stall
back in a box
[Music]
humans only have one ending get that
Barbie
ideas flew forever
[Music]
no I won't let you do just one
appendectomy but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor I need a clicky pen
No a sharp thing no there he is Doctor
somebody gets security
[Music]
if you're still in doubt
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up to you guys
tonight is our night we're getting in
the couch I'm gonna talk to Brittany you
get that Isabel what would I say hey
girl how's your boyfriend how's his
penis
[Music]
spell you both for committing a crime
against Jeff get out of the car
we were just practicing for a
self-defense Club it's like a Fight Club
yes stay in your lane until you're
munching Beaver Wesleyan yes sir
what's your plan here Jeff is psychotic
and they're picking on the weak and
defenseless so we teach a bunch of girls
how to defend themselves they are
grateful to us adrenaline is Flowing
next thing you know Isabelle and
Brittany are kissing us on the mouse
you can be our club advisor you know my
mom did say I need to pick up a hobby
Club face
[Applause]
I have a safe space like this it means a
lot to people I'm gonna finally reverse
stock my stalker yeah I'll be able to
kill my stepdad awesome it seems so
supportive of women especially the hot
ones man-made therapy
are you cheating on me I literally saw
you yesterday sub nerd I [__] your mom
we are literally at the bottom we have
nowhere to cope it up
[Music]
if you deserve a shot at telling
everybody how [__] cool they are I
that's the [__] up to the football place
I want that trophy you created a Fight
Club to get some coaching
I know y'all ain't tickling the Pearl I
just don't know if you're supposed to be
talking to us like that just like as a
teacher
the case Santos
not on your lights
hello girls
it's the last body shot competition so
we are gonna assault a you up I've had
it with love I don't believe it's
relevant to the 21st century lesbian
you're not wearing that I just came from
work I came from Toledo I don't dress
like it I'm not here to Pedal my Wares
I'm leaving town I am too that was my
plan where are you going Tallahassee
Florida I've been unhappy that's why we
take this trip together home babe we get
our act together together
girlie's driveway Pennsylvania's most
trusted name in car delivery here don't
call me curly
and your name curly my name is Curly we
just met it's too familiar
we're here for the car wait a minute you
call with a drop off in Tallahassee and
then these broads come in and say
they're ready to go to Tallahassee they
drive the car instead of you is that bad
bad if they find the goods
okay
what we should see what's in here I bet
it's locked
[Music]
[Applause]
I understand that you're unhappy sir we
will find and deliver the package we
just want your friends
you cannot relate to the public which in
the service profession is a big handicap
did the two creeps find you well they
know we have their stuff maybe we sell
it back shake them down all right they
like wanted or something oh no they're
not in trouble at all I'm gonna help you
break a big murder case that is about
the dumbest thing I've ever heard and
I'm a cop
everybody
who are you Democrats
wow you've had a full day
[Music]
I've been having it
the strangest dreams
Rachel dreams are not reliable
analytical material that's so 20th
century
hi Rachel we're delighted to let you
know that we've had movement on our wait
list
we got a spot at the womb Center
but I haven't told Elvia
yet
[Music]
he wants a natural child
but hold on you put us on a waitlist to
have a baby in the name no it's not an
egg it's it's an egg
women are reluctant to have children
because it's not made convenient we want
them to pursue their careers and dreams
we can't live in the past I want to have
a child with you let's do it really yeah
I'm sure you're all very excited parents
are raving about it it is the ultra
solution
my nephew was born at the boom Center
but he doesn't dream I wouldn't worry
about it
[Music]
I can't do it with a pot in here what
are you talking about it can't see us
I feel Alvey is able to bond with a
child but I'm not
maybe I'm just not ready to be a mother
you know no one's a mother just like
that you become one
we are considering having a home birth
I'm sorry it's not possible I won't
raise this child without nature
congratulations it's so exciting isn't
it
I noticed a change in productivity you
do have a baby at the womb center right
why
[Music]
your family Dynamics are about to
undergo tremendous changes
foreign
how can we make sure our baby's not
bored in utero oh yeah we don't want any
board babies
[Music]
today is going to be the best day ever I
love sunshine I love butterflies but
more than anything I love Doug hey
shut the [__] up you [__] piece of
[__] that's Doug the best owner in the
world
we're playing this game called Fetch and
[__] [__] he drops me off really far
away and drives home without me when I
bring the ball back he says [__] that's
how I know I won the game
hey honey you ever been with an Afghan
before I don't think so what thank you
thank you for me kid he left your ass oh
that can't be right you are officially
astray that would mean
duck doesn't love me poor little guy I
should probably talk to him I am a
therapy dog Fred you can learn how
beautifully conceived when you're off
the League this beer is making me dizzy
he's about to get real Dizzy up in this
[__] I'm having a great time this
[__] right here
little [__] ass friend with the
[__] home perm and [__] what
did you just say
you can do anything you want I'm going
back to Doug's what the [__] man he
needs to pay for what he did with the
only thing he truly loves I'm gonna bite
his dick off oh wait did he just say
Mike yeah I'm still a little drunk but I
said I'm gonna bite his dick off oh we
gon [__] [__] up [__] you don't
know me like that
big day today you ever humped anything
before I wouldn't say I've humped or
saved there you go red I'm doing good
tell him you're his dad hey noem I'm
your father it's good to finally meet
you right even under these strange
circumstances
he's lost and my little puppy paw pads
are really hurting right now so
holy [__]
oh [__] guys we've got a dick to ripoff
what are those kind of looks like food
oh [__] uh give me a second you look
different [__] you look different too
how so is it my human hands
wait
I should warn you before you step inside
the house this could change the course
of your entire life I'm not afraid of a
couple ghosts
you say that now
this Mansion is unhinged
these ghosts definitely don't want to
leave death lurks around every corner
God give us a break there's so many bad
people in the world haunt them amen
I do like surprises is anybody else seen
this
we're in a fight whether we like it or
not or else we're stuck here for
eternity
if this comes down to an exorcism
but there's always room
for one more
friend was mugged he was tall he had
hair that was sticking out of a what a
top hat Top Hat yes he had yeah it's
like Top Hat you would pull a rabbit out
of it probably uh eyes they were a bit
uh
like a raccoon they sit back
and he was smiling like yeah like that
exactly is this the man who mugged you
wow you just did that just now
hi mind if I touch your wiener what dog
stop Gary court order for acid seizures
so they're taking my car you and radio
silent on me is that what this is about
my feelings for you were so intense that
I got scared is that true
that's my cousin Gary I swear to God
he's my cousin he's my second cousin
there's something seriously wrong with
you
I'm an Uber driver and I don't have a
car I'm gonna lose my house
foreign
College in exchange will give you a
Buick Regal date is in quotes
husband the code breaker
he's just been so worried about our son
he's going to Princeton in the fall no
I've heard of it and we tried everything
to bring him out of his shell he doesn't
come out of his room he doesn't talk to
girls and drinks so when you say date
him do you mean date him or date him yes
datum date him hard I'll date his brains
out he volunteers at the animal shelter
hi mind if I touch your wiener what your
dog
how about I give you a ride home
um this isn't the way to my house it's a
shortcut you're my hostage but you got
down there something for me
kid is Undateable have a drink together
he'll have a Long Island Iced Tea
[Music]
it's the worst iced tea I've ever had
okay
know what to do I just know my mom would
have wanted me to save the house I feel
like just nervous why don't you loosen
them up you can just skinny dipping what
about sharks none here jellyfish not the
season it's really the lack of life
partner
right okay
I'm just a bit of a romantic he's
actually really sweet the best part
about getting older is not having to
care what people think I'm an adult now
I can make my own decisions that's good
you want to save her save her
come on you're getting out of here you
don't belong here touch me get away from
her
[Music]
ah
Maddie you can't outrun the car I can't
lose my license
I never fit in anywhere too Iranian in
America to American and Iran
the only way to survive was to not put
my faith in any of the rules nice
cultural commentary
obviously I've had some issues with
culture can you blame me
what's she saying I'm pregnant how can
you be so irresponsible this is my mom
and I's relationship in a nutshell
that's really her she's the queen of
stubbornness a trait I'd later go on to
perfect
Elena Hi how are you evidently better
than you
I'm trying it's not all my mom's fault I
believe in you but it's so much easier
blaming on mothers how do you say
goodbye in Persian Cafe sure everybody
[Music]
trust me on this
ah you guys must be new to town right
new to town but not new to the country
we just moved from California oh we just
wondered uh if you wouldn't mind if your
daughter played with our daughter Audrey
say hi
fly
slides off limits to Ching chongs
do you want to be best friends look at
me look at me look at me now guess who's
going back to the motherland it's a big
deal going to your birth country to talk
about it all the time when we're little
remember Grand Adventure to find your
birth mother so proud of you
y'all calling me crazy my translator in
Beijing Audrey I got you ready
[Laughter]
Kat lives there now your famous college
roommate are you ready to lose to a
celebrity
oh Dead Eye is coming by the way get out
your cousin hey Audrey oh hi hey where
did that come from
you know I think I get it I called the
adoption agency and she lives in high
chain okay will you guys come with me
[__] yes [__] I love a grand Adventure
oh hi so nice to see an American what do
you do for work it's the cops are doing
a back check
[Music]
it's now [__] what the [__] is that a
condom we can't get caught with drugs in
China we'll get jailed for life
never come to China people are always
thinking that I have this perfect life I
don't belong anywhere if you do not know
where you come from how do you know who
you are
we could still find her our passports
are in my suitcase that got stolen no we
can bypass airport security K-pop Stars
everyone remember their names sassy Lisa
Lisa too I don't believe these girls are
singers girls show them
um what are we supposed to show you're a
fan of cardi B right yeah is she here
there's some [__] in this house
there's some horse
you're good did you get the coke bags
out yeah but only seven and I think I
put an eight just push pull pull I mean
it's not a puppet it's my [__]
you're not here we're not there the car
exploded
come get the girls I have to stay here
with Woodrow another chauffeur I'm the
grandfather where are you asteroid City
farm Route 6 Mile 75.
Junior star gazers and Space Cadets each
year we celebrate asteroid day
commemorating September 23 3007 BC when
the Arid Plains meteorite made Earth
you're very good in the one about the
[__] in the brothel who gets amnesian
pediatrician you were very honestly
maybe my favorite character I don't know
why nobody else liked it
what do those pulses indicate what oh
the beeps and blips we don't know some
of our information about outer space May
no longer be completely accurate anyway
there's still only nine planets in the
solar system as far as we know Billy
except now there's an alien
foreign
like we're doomed
maybe we are I've just been born the
president how long can they keep us an
asteroid City legally the world will
never be the same that's the alien doing
jumping jacks that's an alien on Top Hat
what's out there the meaning of life
maybe there is one are you married I'm a
widower but don't tell my kids you're
saying her mother died three weeks ago
let's say she's in heaven which doesn't
exist for me of course but you're
Episcopalian in my loneliness I learned
to give complete and unquestioning Faith
to the people I love I don't know if
that includes you but it included my
daughter and your four children
sometimes I think I feel more at home
outside the Earth's atmosphere oh wow
me too they're strange aren't they
they're children
compared to normal people yes that's
correct it's true
going so fast
I do a nude scene you want to see it
did I say yes you didn't say anything I
meant yes my mouth didn't speak
[Music]
10 years ago we created the robots who
now do the tasks Americans once did
Thomas Newton who was sentenced to 28
years after he had an illegal robot
double of himself you hear that robot
yes
Hugo is different level I'm glad you've
met a nice young lady I need you
completely focused on getting a
horizontal for me put yourself a deep
program and I'll see you too
Charles guy really wants to bang me so
you'll have to take over tomorrow too
yes Elaine just don't want the night to
end
thank you
pick up your phone I've never done this
before
he also has a robot double you are
dating a robot all along the two and I
are running away together don't try to
stop us what goodbye Elaine goodbye
let's just talk about this don't do it
childish
this is terrible they've completely
stolen our lives I'm gonna have to get a
real job we hunt them down and we kill
them um two cappuccinos thank you you
guys don't understand they're not going
to be obedient anymore
they're humanizing they're learning to
feel you want to get married immediately
let's go away to stop our wedding
enjoy ride is over
hey I get to shoot me sorry I couldn't
resist we'll find that I'm shooting you
that's not fair
oh my God oh my God
she's deprogrammed now she's feral you
want a Pinky Winky
I sent you the royal wedding the simple
instructions
don't cause an international incident
how's it going
you've done some pretty stupid things in
your day but this thanks for cake
[Music]
Henry shoved me an urge I currently
saved
what I need is some good old-fashioned
damaged control
the White House and the palace are going
to release a joint statement
you've got to be choking you can hate
Prince Henry all you want my NDA is
bigger than yours I want you to know
that you're wearing lifts no not too
sweet home you better act like the
Sunshine's out of his ass and you have a
vitamin D deficiency I think Excellence
is what you might say to convince the
world that we're actually friends I love
hanging out by this guys
[Music]
you're expecting at my New Year's party
I do something wrong you don't wonder
who you'd be if you were an anonymous
person in the world I have no idea what
you're talking about
[Music]
yourself it's your Royal Highness
dear Alex I miss you
we are in a hotel problem with reporters
if anyone sees you leave this hotel I
will brexit your head from your body
your Royal Highness
figure out if you feel forever about him
do you love him more difference for the
man if I did
Prince Henry belongs to Britain
you figure out a way to love each other
on our own terms
like there's a rope attached to my chest
and he's pulling me towards you
hopefully we'll get through tonight
without any more scandals
the night is young Ma
this is the story of Alejandro
father gave him everything but she had a
recurring dream of Alejandro leaving the
safe world she created where he'd face
the dangers he tried so hard to keep him
from
Los Angeles
Alejandro Martinez yes Mr Khalil is
ready for you thank you
you have a month to find someone to
cosign your visa and if you don't you
have to leave the US I started
freelancing for this lady I'm late I
know I'm late I'm so late for this menu
what is it with walnuts walnuts walnuts
walnuts it's like a cafe for squirrels
well walnuts they go very nicely with
the salad do I don't like I need
educating on fine cuisine
yeah you think this lady can sponsor you
I I mean we'll see we'll see
oh
is this your dream making toys yeah help
me curate an exhibitions
the other thing is you can't take money
right now you must find a sponsor and
pay fees who earn money the maze is
impossible to navigate wait I mean this
sucks so much for you
your boss is a monster I need to get
paid
it's not a nightmare none of those
options
my question if you are ready for this
job why are you making everything so
difficult
[Music]
journeying into the unknown
it sounds Brave
[Music]
El Salvador
who pooses yes I know sir nuns they
killed in the 80s right so
you know you really captured his Essence
maybe his face can use a lot more detail
though
it's like a photograph
I'm Adam
Chloe
[Music]
sure you're not gonna make fun of me
all right
oh my God
this might be the nicest thing anyone's
ever done for me
[Music]
you have 62 viewers and 300 total
they don't have love in their culture
they find romantic stuff super exotic
and interesting
they watch you'll go on dates
cherished human rituals
[Music]
hey would you keep that [__] out of my
line of sight why don't you keep your
[__] out of arlana's side you didn't
invent courtship broadcast [__]
foreign
the title of your broadcast is Adam and
Chloe in love and yet you are not in
love
I want you to repay all funds you have
received wait we've already spent
everything we made just to live
then I will
attend your families will be in debt for
a sex Generations
do you want me to cut that for you
where is the nearest restaurant
no part of my body can make that noise
well it certainly won't if you don't try
romantic love is the most poetic of all
human love modes it should never be
faked
I'm just like any other person I want to
grow up and fall in love and be swept
off my feet
we've lost a lot since you guys came
here
but we've overcome a lot too
foreign
[Music]
tically the only non-white person in my
entire high school and you never felt
discriminated again I definitely did but
not because I was Asian because of your
inherent bad personality exactly
I applied for what about it
New York New York is overrated it's so
gentrified now how many times have you
even been there are we counting layovers
you always assume the worst about me and
then you end up acting crazy over
nothing I'm not acting crazy so stop
using that word
you're just proving my point
are you two like broken up we're taking
some time off while the cat's away the
mouse will play with himself probably
can I kiss you
sorry I'm a little out of practice
it's clear
[Music]
I'm gonna go to New York listen maybe
you could come with me I thought you
came out here to clear your head I did
and then I met Meredith and I've been
there ever since so when are you gonna
see her I mean I'm here to see Miko
she's an intern here actually I'm the
only intern here
there's some problems with anger
depression your weird self-hatred
[Music]
I know you're going to want to blame
this on society or on your race or
whatever but this really is just about
you this is your rock bottom
look at that guy they're being adorable
finally get to meet you mysterious
boyfriend
is anyone sitting here no
laughs
[Music]
we all write our own stories there is
Richard I'd like to speak to him I'm
here
this time
that's me Mr Richard Montagne I'm the
guy who helped bring the world the most
popular snack it's ever seen are you
ready
I've been ready all right all right it
was a little bit more like this
spicy see that's how I got here dear God
please forgive me for the gang the drugs
it's going cars what the heck man let's
move it hey he's
the guy started at the very bottom I
know I don't look it but I got a BHD I'm
poor hungry and determined sir okay I
can see you're gonna be a weird one
what's happening
Frito-Lay isn't getting enough orders to
keep the Factory open oh he's a cool
ranch anyway
[Applause]
that lady
what is it
stop eating it I like it it was good I
had been searching for an answer
and there it was
they had been there the entire time
you're a good idea it's a spicy kit it's
gonna change everything and we'll save
our Factory and you're a janitor we're
gonna go hang on
figure out the next step say the
Hispanic market will not be ignored the
Hispanic market will not be ignored it's
good but in your voice
we're wasting time on this janitors
crazy idea guys like you and me we'll
get shots like this you see that guy
right there I see a chingon Montana
[Music]
thank you
I got a little Hood there at the end but
[Applause]
[Music]
it's good
it's known as the beautiful game but
let's face it it's a complicated game
guys soccer as you like to call it is
like life next season I think we have a
real shot
I'm sorry uh Thomas did nobody tell you
you're you're fired
good news is you got two options option
one that's where you're currently at or
American Samoa are you serious
we haven't scored one goal in the
history of our country trying to have a
soccer team
start again humiliation mark my words
things are going to change I got us a
new coach
something to drink whiskey beer wine yep
we got all those which one whiskey beer
and wine
it's safe to say you have zero talent
for understanding of the game
you're right about the sky what he is
white
you've got the toughest job on the
island
what we want is just one goal one goal
come on guys we've worked too long and
hard for this you've only been here a
few days
I can't work with these guys for them
it's like some sort of game it is a game
Palace
that's a child leadership now we're
making some progress
thank you for sending us Mr rongan we've
become quite attached to him it's like
finding a little lost white kid at the
mall and telling him which way to go
me
well welcome back to the New Jersey math
Olympics State final Candace youngster
win it all and it is Prince Mattel at
the buzzer do you believe in miracles
happy first day of seventh grade did you
have another math dream yep did you win
yep nice come on here comes the two to
the three and four I'm so excited this
year we have some 12 year olds joining
our high school class who's ready to get
marinated
I actually need some help with something
it's about Dad msm2 Prime I'll never
know who I am unless I know who he was
your father had a real way with words
wait Dad was a rapper for real what's
his name probably haven't heard of him
he died when I was five
hi
wait why are we yelling dad
Seth are you ghost a goat no I'm too old
for an imaginary friend well you're too
young for a midlife crisis but here we
are who is brain Patel
that's not me I can't rap why not hip
hop is in your DNA
this methol thinks he's a rapper now
you've got in school when the real world
you'll always be a loser
hey truth is bullies are afraid of
dreamers
[Music]
Supreme you you love math
listen to me this is inside you
riding in cars with high schoolers
do they Vape no matter where we go just
do you do your best that's what's
important
[Music]
let's give map to Native people
[Applause]
a lot has happened since My Big Fat
Greek Wedding
my father passed away and His Last Wish
was for us to visit his childhood
Village and reconnect with our Roots so
we're having a reunion we're going to
Greece oh yeah
[Music]
and by Lee I mean
the whole family who wants souvlucky
Beijing Souvlaki anybody by the name of
sulaki on his flight
Aristotle what I didn't know you were
going to be here you're doing here I had
an amazing date
she ghosted him
you are the protocols family we are
related to your public
purpose was married to my great great
Yaya sister sustaino
I learned I will be your favorite
I promised my dad I would find his best
friends I know them do they still live
here no how do we find them they will
come for the reunion did they tell you
they're coming no
other bedrooms family sleepover
we'll never forget do you know do you
know man no I am surprised but I am not
surprised because I'm never surprised
you lost me
we dreamed about Aristotle last night
how did you know Greek Voodoo bam I
remember your story I really need to
find my dad's friends Angelo and I are
on it okay bye
amazing
[Music]
let's do it
I'm calling it you got us back to Greece
you're the head of the family now I
can't really Day drink like this don't
worry a lady is never drunk
it's the one we have for dinner oh thank
you uh I'm a vegetarian
no
[Music]
fear Nathan
it engulfs you
plagued by your nightmarish memories
unless you are Vigilant you will drown
the end of days are not the metal Oculus
is upon us
um hi
what the Doom star
it creeps closer to our atmosphere every
day threatening cataclysmic destruction
salacia only he knows what vile Evils
are in store
we must Journey out to find the song of
salvation
what is the song of Salvation nobody
knows well do we at least know the
running time now thus we at least knows
what keys
what happens if we do it wrong
the world will be made in blood
the Earth
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
on June 16th
wait hold up I know I left his dog see
the horror film
preview audiences are calling a killer
experience
probably runs on racism
[Music]
you've sacrificed the person you deemed
the blackest guys I can prove them not
the blackest prove it I thought black
Twitter was a type of seasoning I like
Jimmy Fallon without the roots and wrong
I voted for Trump
what
twice
your time is up it's time to die
[Music]
cops
[Applause]
we need a plan let's get the weapons
wait chili powder girl what I'm gonna do
cook sorry
all right
even gotta save everyone another damn
time
[Music]
can we just go lock the doors get down
I'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]